um
our forces
got the order to should to kill
the russian uh paratroopers in hostile
yes we have losses
we have
some prisoners of war
um uh from russia our uh uh doctors are
helping the russians who surrendered
uh we destroyed a lot of
uh
planes of uh
warplanes and uh
some armored vehicles some of the
russians uh they saying that they're
against the war in the saw in
social media but i doubt it if the
russian authorities will see that
that's why
yeah i will ask you
if you hear us if you understand us if
you understand and realize that you're
advancing to the
uh
to the independent country just please
go out and
address your authorities and your
president
now your
military started war
war in our country
and i really wanted that you
you uh express yourself uh red square or
elsewhere in your capital moscow saint
petersburg some other
uh
cities and towns of russia
not only in instagram it's very
important
what we see uh at this moment russia
is
turning
into
uh version of dnr
uh full isolation
of
russia
just started getting big sanctions from
the
uh powerful the most powerful history
sanctions package
nobody will force us ukrainians to give
away our freedom uh independence our
sovereignty
but it looks like
the russian
leadership is trying to
uh
to do it just by the way of
destroying their own country
now
everything is getting burned quite
literally in front of the whole
world
we
emphasize it's not ukraine who chose a
path of war
but ukraine
calls
[Music]
join our territorial defense and armed
if forces have
a military experience it will be very
very useful
and
then we will uh defend our independent
country
please help the volunteers and medical
uh workers
uh for instance uh giving blood
and
the politicians and the local leaders
should be helped
just um make sure that the life is
normal as long as as far as you could
could do as far as a life could be
normal
and you just take care of your neighbors
of your friends
and
now to to the journalists
defend the democracy and the freedom of
ukraine
i spoke today
with uh with the world leaders with the
great britain usa sweden uh german
poland austria romania
and many others
if you
dear european leaders
dear world leaders
leaders of the free world if you won't
help us today
if
you
didn't show your strength of help
war will be knocking
at your door
glory to ukraine glory to
the ukraine armed forces
[Music]